et pour parler de cette dernière
recommandation de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé au sujet du remdh
et y virent avec nous stéphane caillet
infectiologues au chu de strasbourg et
gilbert collard député européen du
rassemblement national
bonsoir messieurs merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation à leur première
question je m'adresse à vous monsieur
collard elle vous étonne sept
recommandations de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé de ne pas
administrer leur md et virent aux
malades du comité 19 hospitalisé mais
moi ce qui m'étonne c'est que l'union
européenne ait pu passer commande comme
vous l'avez tout à leur signaler et ce
qui m'étonne c'est qu'on ait pu faire le
procès de la chloroquine en vantant les
mérites grain dé et vire alors que
maintenant on nous dit après que la
chahuter fait que le médicament serait
sans effet tout cela vous prenez
contribuer à créer un climat non par
complotistes mais d'incertitude
d'inquiétude et de d'insuffisance
scientifique
quand on voit les sommes d'argent qui
ont été dépensés sur le plan européen en
faveur de ce médicament dont l' oms nous
dit maintenant qu'il n'est pas
opérationnel et je crois que c'est un
point qui est scientifiquement acquis
sauf évolution
on est obligé de se poser la question de
savoir pourquoi en finance pourquoi on
achète un traitement dont on sait
maintenant qu'il n'est pas efficace et
bon vous posez la question à vous à
monsieur monsieur gascon
pourquoi est-ce qu'on finance et ou
qu'on a utilisé ce médicament dans le
traitement du coït 19
alors cette question du remdh et y vit
excusez moi mais un véritable scandale
et c'est un très vieil antiviral qui
avait été développé initialement contre
le virus du sida
il n'était pas efficace ensuite il a été
essayé contre le virus ebola
il n'était pas efficace il est largement
utilisé en revanche anges
chine mais pour soigner les chats qui
sont atteintes d'une péritonite à kona
virus et selon un marché un peu curieux
et alors le laboratoire et gilles ead
essaie à tout prix parce qu'il a
beaucoup investi dans cette molécule de
lui trouver un débouché et il a fait le
forcing pour essayer de convaincre les
uns et les autres que c'était le produit
d'avenir pour traiter lakovic 19
or il n'en est rien si on regarde toutes
les études qui ont été menées depuis le
début de l'année depuis le mois de
février
on voit très bien que leur md et vire à
un très faible service rendu tout ce que
dans l une a pu constater c'est que
alors déjà c'est un médicament
uniquement hospitalier des injectables
il est extrêmement coûteux si on veut le
comparer à l'hydroxyte le rock in il
coûte 30 fois plus cher le seul service
rendu que l'on ait pu constater et
encore avec du mal c'est que chez des
malades gravement atteints de la copie
il diminue légèrement la durée
d'hospitalisation
c'est tout c'est à dire que les gens
peuvent sortir un peu plus tôt donc ce
serait menée et vire tous les médecins
qui s'intéressent à la question
infectiologues et des biologistes sont
atterrés par le crédit qu'on accorde à
cette molécule
alors que manifestement il n'est pas
efficace quand la coved 19 ou à peine et
que qui plus est il est toxique
c'est à dire qu'il a une toxicité pour
plusieurs organes notamment le rhin
alors si si c'est pas alors je suis au
principe dit nous dit nous stéphane
gagné comment est ce qu il a pu se
retrouver et bien sûr le marché ce
médicament puisque vous dites qu'il est
innée toxiques alors c'est comment
financer alors moi il a pu se retrouver
sur le marché
il a dû être bien appuyé il a dû être un
bénéfice et bénéficier d'appuis
parce que sinon c'est incompréhensible
il est il et c'est un produit qui est
soutenu voilà gilbert collard ce n'est
pas la première fois que l' oms
dénonce les l'inefficacité de ce
médicament pourtant début octobre
la commission européenne a commandé plus
de 500 mille doses à gilead son
fabricant comment vous l'expliquez ça
non mais je ne nous l'expliquent que par
le syndrome d'ali baba et là la caverne
des 40 voleurs
y'a pas d'autre explication possible
quand vous pensez qu'on a mis en place
d'une manière médiatique
une manière systématique d'une manière
politique d'une manière ordinale
l'accusation de l'hydroxyde chloroquine
médicaments vieux de 70 ans médicaments
peu coûteux et que parallèlement on a
enclenché la promotion supersonique et
super saut fric dur md et vire en se en
on ne peut pas être dupe je viens il ya
un moment donné il faut ouvrir les yeux
et se rendre compte qu'on est le bétail
d'un système pharmaco financier qui a
décidé de rentabiliser nos vies je veux
dire que le site un discours qui est
politiquement pas correct mais il faut
abandonner avant le courage de le dire
on est devenus du du bétail le sanitaire
commerciale et la sphère du remdh et et
vire le démontre
d'un côté on à l'achat par l'union
européenne et par diverses structures
d'état de ce médicament
on avait dit à tiques mans et là ça pose
des questions aussi la promotion de
cette thérapeutique alors que cela vient
de vous être expliquée remarquablement
et cela a été déjà expliqué si tu avais
différents toxiques et inefficace alors
vous allez en même temps on fond soir on
renvoie et j'ai conclu là dessus et en
même temps renvoie le professeur raout
devant le conseil de l'ordre création au
passage quand même du régime
pour mémoire de vichy vous êtes d'accord
stéphane caillet on est devenus du
bétail sanitaire commercial c'est pas
les fusions j'oriente payet mais les
l'idée est là c'est c'est un scandale
et innommable en face et c'est qu'il n'y
a pas de mot pour qualifier ce qui se
passe c'est il ya un mépris de la vie
des gens ce médicament et en plus il est
très coûteux alors il nous endettent et
c'est au mépris de la vie des gens on a
écarté d'hydroxyde chloroquine qui rend
des services puisque de très nombreux
médecins généralistes l'utilisent dans
de très nombreux pays du monde vide roxy
chloroquine en association avec
l'azithromycine il faut le préciser
alors justement rappelé on va rappeler
ce chiffre il voudra peut-être dire
quelque chose
le remdh et zivi rapporté fin octobre
près de 900 millions de dollars à gilead
sciences
son fabricant au troisième trimestre
c'est là que tout se joue en fait sur le
plan financier
si je comprends bien alors juste nos ms
depuis le début de la pandémie de covile
19 elle souffle le chaud et le froid sur
de nombreux sujets mais elle multiplie
les recommandations parfois qui se
contredisaient ce qu'il faut accorder
continuer d'accorder du crédit à
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
gilbert collard écoutez franchement pour
ne pas faire de la langue de bois le
cercueil des démocraties
je n'y comprends plus rien on a
l'impression qu'on a un ami en place
d'aidés des bureaux technocrates
totalement incompétent je suis pas
médecin donc je tâtonne dans tout ce que
je dis il faut voir marc m'en excuser
j'ai un entourage médical autour de moi
quand même et de qualité mais on a
l'impression que que on a affaire à des
guerres picrocholines l affaire à des
guerres entre des groupes
pharmaceutiques des entités professoral
des autorités universitaires d'aidé et
par leur médiatique des vengeurs
hollande qui viennent ici faire la leçon
la régler des comptes
on a l'impression que c'est un désordre
absolu et le
le quidam il se dit mais si c'est ça la
recherche scientifique
si c'est ça la science ya de quoi avoir
peur et puis on a vu apparaître aussi je
conclus cette génération incroyable de
médecins dits de santé qui sont des
médecins administrative qui en général
n'ont pas vu beaucoup de malades qui
sont des techniciens et spécialistes de
la statistique qui n'ont vu d'ordonnancé
ou d'hormones ans réglementaire pad
ordonnance médicale
et ils viennent d rhorer sur les chaînes
de télé donné des consignes des
indications alors que la plupart d'entre
eux n'ont pas vu de malades depuis 10
ans 15 ans et on ne dénonce pas la
présence de ces médecins administratif
et en néglige les médecins de terrain
les vrais médecins médecin de famille le
généraliste acquis en défens quasiment
de prescrire des antibiotiques à qui on
a retiré le droit de faire des des
textes enfin c'est quand même temps mais
la seule explication qu'on peut avoir
c'est que on à la 7ème compagnie pour
faire la guerre contre le virus
franchement je ne comprends plus rien
c'est les gens qui m'entourent n'y
comprennent plus rien si ce n'est que la
7ème compagnie est au pouvoir
stéphane caillet rapidement le mot de la
fin pour conclure ce double entretient
un mot peut-être sur l' oms
l'organisation mondiale de la santé ce
qu'il faut continuer à lui accorder du
crédit
déjà je confirme bien entendu ce que dit
gilbert collard c'est une affaire
purement financière c'est à dire qu'il
ya un mépris total de la santé publique
dé santé individuelle tout ce qui compte
c'est les bénéfices et il faut qu'ils
soient le plus important possible ré ce
ne ne compte pas c'est le profit
toujours plus de profits et on est prêt
à sacrifier des gens pour cela alors
concernant le msb depuis le début de la
pandémie
l'attitude de l'om est ce ces
recommandations se sont vraiment ambiguë
et on a l'impression qu'elle est sous
influence
effectivement et elle est le lot et metz
ne donne absolument pas l'image d'un
organisme neutre qu'il devrait être
eh bien ce sera le mot de la fin
stéphane caillet merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
infectiologues au chru de strasbourg
merci à vous également gilbert collard
député européen du rassemblement
national